[موسيقى]
افتكر لك ايه هذا ما يفترض انها اغنيه
جديده لكوكب الشرق ام كلثوم كما قدمها
ملحنها عمرو مصطفى الذي استحضر صوتها بعد
عقود من وفاتها عبر تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي ما ان نشر الجزء الترويجي من
الاغنيه التي وعد باطلاقها كامله في وقت
قريب حتى هبت عاصفه الجدل والانتقادات في
مصر واعتبر مدونون الخطوه
تعديا صارخا على حقوق الملكيه الفكريه
للمطربه الراحله
وطالبوه بالتراجع عنها فهم يرون ان الصوت
الموجود في اغنيه افتكر لك ايه بعيد كل
البعد عن صوت ام كلثوم المصنفه ضمن
المطربين الذين شكلوا التاريخ الفني
[موسيقى]
حياتي
عذاب
فيما وصف المنتج ومالك اغاني ام كلثوم
محسن جابر التجربه بانها عبث وتشويه
للتراث واللعب بالنار ورغم الجدل الدائري
على المنصات الرقميه ورفض المنتج الشهير
استخدام صوت سيده الغناء بهذه الطريقه اصر
الملحن عمرو مصطفى على المضي قدما فيما
وصفه بمشروع احياء التراث موقف يشاركه فيه
قله من النشطاء والمدونين الذين اشادوا
بالتجربه علما انه وفق الماده رقم
181 من قانون الحمايه الفكريه
يعاقب القانون المصري بالحبس مده لا تقل
عن شهر وغرامه لا تقل عن الاف جنيه لمن
يعتدي على اي حق ادبي او مالي من حقوق
المؤلف
سيده الغناء العربي حلت في المركز الحادي
والستين ضمن قائمه مجله
الامريكيه لافضل 200 مطرب على مر التاريخ
وقالت المجله انه لا يوجد لام كلثوم نظير
في الغرب وانها عكست روح العالم العربي
لتاتي قصه الاغنيه الجديده في صميم الجدل
العالمي بشان حدود استخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي خاصه في مجالات الفن والابداع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]